the National Library of Medicine proudly
presents farm tastic plastic star in
polymer join her on the farm to help
build plastics
time for environmental games
I love these free games
join me and help Earthlings make good
choices about plastics welcome to farm
tastic plastic our mission is to collect
the goods to make plastics here on the
plastic farm
get pickin
um these aren't Tomatoes this is a
plastic farm those are monomers or
single chemical molecules used to build
long molecules called polymers so all of
these are different monomers there are
so many types monomers are the building
blocks of plastics they are used to make
different types of plastics let's
collect some don't forget the gold we
have collected enough types to earn a
star expand your farm collect 3 styrene
3 isocyanate so much for free gaming
let's check out that patch over there
these are big ones yes monomers can be
simple or complex these monomers are
larger molecules with more atoms
ethylene oxide and bisphenol a styrene
and dimethyl terephthalate want to build
faster get more monomer baskets sounds
like a pretty good deal to me pushy
aren't they looks like we filled our
basket again congratulations you've
unlocked the polymerization mill
polymers polymers are just long chains
of monomers that are chemically
connected through covalent bonds
covalent bonds are the strongest bonds
between atoms ah they both connect
that's right remember plastics are
synthetic polymers made of monomers
combined through a chemical reaction not
naturally occurring in nature but made
by humans humans discovered how to make
plastics in 1856 ok but how do we get
them to stick together
it depends polymerization reactions need
heat pressure or the presence of a
catalyst another chemical in order to
connect the monomers together to form
polymers
so that's why we need the polymerization
reaction mill it provides the things
needed to combine the monomers into
polymers let's try it this one is using
the catalyst titanium 3 chloride to
speed up the reaction
grab some ethene monomers Wow
I think monomers are expensive to
produce polymerizing oh we have to wait
time to browse the monomer pellet
catalog limited edition monomers only a
dollar ninety-nine I thought my biology
teacher told me we have polymers in her
bodies we don't have plastic in us
though do we
no plastic we do have natural polymers
occurring in nature without human
intervention things like DNA protein and
polysaccharides a type of sugar these
are all natural polymers made of various
natural monomers they require cellular
energy and enzymes to catalyze those
polymerization reactions one our sales
yeah
nothing predatory going on here at all
it's done oh look they are all stuck
together now I can't pull them apart oh
I see the double bonds from the monomers
are now just single bonds that's how the
monomers were able to stick together the
double bond and the monomer is broken
and a single chemical bond is formed
between the monomers yep a covalent bond
very strong this is polyethylene
sometimes called polyethylene even
though it's a polymer now it's named
after the monomer molecule ethene but
what if I used a different monomer you'd
make a different polymer polymers can be
made of only one type of monomer or
different repeating types of monomers
wait a second this is just like a string
how is this
how does this whole soda pop come play
in our other plastics as most people
think of them soda bottles furniture
phone cases are just lots of those
little strands next to each other
how they are held together though
defines the two thermoplastics and
thermosets thermoplastics are sheets of
polymer strands held together through
weak intermolecular bonds when heated
the strands separate the plastic melts
and can be remoted into different shapes
these types of plastics can be truly
recycled into something else
thermoset plastics are helped together
through strong covalent chemical bonds
between the molecules of one strand in
another created through a process called
cross-linking this makes a very strong
matrix that won't melt when heated it
also means that you can't make a new
item out of those plastics you can
repurpose the plastic by chopping it
into small pieces but it will never melt
okay so the thermoplastics are like ice
cubes I can melt them and refreeze them
into different shapes whereas the
thermosets are like a raw egg once I
cook it it can never be a raw egg again
the thermoplastic polyvinyl chloride PVC
here we go
make your PVC blue I am thought about
that plastics do come in all colors make
your plastic or lightweight fillers make
the plastic lighter reduce costs
stabilize and sometimes make them
somewhat fireproof your PVC is too
brittle plasticize it I thought we just
made plastic plasticizers are chemicals
added to the mix of monomers to give the
plastic different properties phthalates
are chemical plasticizers that are used
in PVC to make them more flexible
finally weird it smells funny those are
the plasticizers escaping the plastic
they can be health hazards make the
thermoset plastic bakelite weird this
time our ingredients are liquid yes
remember these types form covalent bonds
between polymer strands after they cure
or set they are usually in liquid form
to begin with and over a period of time
will become a hard solid plastic many of
these are used as coatings like
polyurethane on furniture polymerizing
time remaining 24 hours 24 hours guess
I'll check on that tomorrow time to feed
the fungus pardon me this may be a
plastic farm but we still have critters
to feed this fungus is one of the few
species of fungi and bacteria found to
digest synthetic polymers like plastics
but they only decompose specific
plastics and specific conditions so they
are not enough to save Earth from
plastics that are not recycled that one
wants PVC so humans can
choose to produce some plastics that
will be better for the planet
six hours later Olivia honey what are
farm bills and why did I just get a call
from the phone company about a five
hundred dollar charge for them